(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Bom, estamos aqui na nossa primeira aula do
módulo 2.
Esse módulo é exclusivamente dedicado ao estudo do
leilão excrediticial.
Então a gente vai passar por tudo que
é necessário para que você possa fazer uma
arrematação segura nessa modalidade de leilão, que é
o leilão excrediticial.
Primeiro a gente vai começar entendendo o que
é o contrato de alienação fiduciária.
Eu já falei anteriormente no curso que a
maioria dos leilões excrediticiais acontece justamente em decorrência
de um contrato de alienação fiduciária.
São os chamados leilões dos bancos.
Então, primeiro, a gente vai entender o que
é o contrato de alienação fiduciária.
O contrato de alienação fiduciária, ele pode ser
de um bem imóvel ou do bem imóvel.
O que interessa aqui para a gente no
curso para estudar o leilão excrediticial é o
contrato de um bem imóvel.
Esse contrato é regulado pela lei 9.514
de 1997.
A alienação fiduciária nada mais é do que
uma garantia contratual.
Alguém vai transferir a propriedade de um bem
para outra pessoa como garantia de um pagamento
de uma dívida.
Então, de um lado nós temos o credor
fiduciário e, do outro lado, o devedor fiduciante.
O credor fiduciário é quem vai emprestar o
dinheiro para o devedor fiduciante.
E o devedor fiduciante é quem transfere a
propriedade do seu bem para o credor fiduciário
como uma garantia de que aquele valor vai
ser pago.
O que é transferido aqui nesse contrato de
alienação fiduciária é o que a gente chama
de propriedade resolúvel.
E por que tem esse nome?
A propriedade é resolúvel porque ela tem uma
forma resolutiva no contrato para ser extinta.
O que significa?
O devedor transferiu a propriedade de um bem
que ele tinha para o credor fiduciário como
uma forma de garantia de que ele vai
pagar determinado valor.
Só que se o devedor pagar a integralidade
desse contrato, essa propriedade resolúvel vai ser extinta
e a propriedade volta a ser plena do
devedor.
Agora, se o devedor não pagar esse contrato,
se ele trazar alguma parcela desse contrato, o
credor pode consolidar a propriedade em seu nome,
ou seja, a propriedade vai ser definitivamente do
credor porque ele vai estar executando aquela garantia
que o devedor deu como pagamento daquela dívida.
Como na alienação fiduciária a garantia é um
bem imóvel, o credor vai consolidar a propriedade
desse bem imóvel e deverá necessariamente vendê-lo
para quitar a dívida do devedor.
Ou seja, é por isso que ocorrem a
maioria dos leilões extrajudiciais, os leilões do banco.
Quais são os requisitos para consolidar a propriedade
em nome do credor?
O que o ele precisa fazer para consolidar
essa propriedade?
Primeiro aqui um parênteses, o credor na maioria
dos casos são bancos ou grandes construtoras, mas
nada impede que seja qualquer outra instituição que
faça esse tipo de contrato, que empreste o
dinheiro para alguém recebendo um bem imóvel como
garantia.
Para facilitar aqui nosso entendimento do curso, a
gente vai falar em banco de uma maneira
geral porque a maioria dos casos, mas fique
na sua mente que não necessariamente vai ser
um banco, pode ser uma construtora ou alguma
outra instituição que trabalhe com esse tipo de
garantia.
Então vamos lá, quais são os requisitos para
consolidar a propriedade no nome do credor?
Primeiro, o devedor deve acrasar o pagamento.
A maioria dos contratos de aliação fiduciária são
financiamentos com várias parcelas, então vai ficar estipulado
no contrato quantas parcelas o devedor tem que
acrasar para começar isso que a gente vai
estudar agora.
Não existe na lei o número de parcelas
fixos, vai ser determinado em cada contrato, então
o credor pode estipular que vai ser uma
parcela em determinado contrato, pode terminar que vão
ser duas parcelas, três parcelas, o mais usual
é que os credores coloquem nos contratos que
são três parcelas, então vão ser necessários o
acraso de três parcelas para que o credor
possa iniciar esse processo de consolidação da propriedade.
Então, em primeiro lugar, o devedor acrasa, em
segundo lugar, o credor vai constituir o devedor
em mora.
O que significa constituir o devedor em mora?
Nada mais é do que você notificar oficialmente
aquela pessoa de que aquela pessoa está te
devendo, então o credor vai fazer uma notificação
e essa notificação obrigatoriamente, no caso da alienação
financeira, deve ser feita pelo cartório de registro
de imóveis que aquele bem está matriculado.
Então, o credor vai chegar ao cartório, vai
pedir para que notifique aquele devedor para constituir
em mora, falar oficialmente que aquele devedor está
em atraso com o credor e, a partir
daí, começa um prazo de 15 dias para
que o devedor purga a mora, ou seja,
para que o credor pague aquilo que ele
está devendo.
Se o devedor estiver pagando três parcelas e
isso foi o estipulado em contrato, que o
credor poderia começar a agir para consolidar a
propriedade com três parcelas em atraso, o devedor
teria que pagar aquelas três parcelas, os juros
daquelas três parcelas para que o credor não
consolida a propriedade.
Caso o devedor pague o que ele está
devendo nesses 15 dias, ok, o contrato de
alienação fiduciária segue como estipulado, não vai ter
a consolidação da propriedade em nome do credor.
Agora, quando o devedor não paga aquilo que
ele está devendo naqueles 15 dias, o credor
poderá consolidar a propriedade.
Como é que vai ocorrer essa consolidação da
propriedade?
O credor vai pagar o ITBI, que é
o Imposto sobre Transmissão de Bens Imóveis, e
vai consolidar a propriedade em seu nome.
Para que ele possa consolidar a propriedade em
seu nome, o cartório de imóveis vai ter
que certificar que naqueles 15 dias o devedor
não purgou a mora, ou seja, não pagou
o que ele devia.
Isso tudo geralmente fica no mesmo registro na
matrícula, vai estar lá que o devedor foi
notificado para purgar a mora, teve 15 dias
para purgar a mora e não purgou a
mora.
Então, o credor recolheu o ITBI, que é
o Imposto sobre Transmissão de Bens Imóveis, e
foi realizada a consolidação da propriedade em nome
do credor.
Uma vez consolidada a propriedade no nome do
credor, o credor, ele necessariamente vai ter que
realizar leilão para alienar aquele bem, ou seja,
para vender aquele imóvel e quitar a dívida
do devedor.
Então, vamos lá recapitulando.
A alienação fiduciária é uma modalidade de contrato
onde alguém, que é o chamado devedor fiduciante,
transfere a propriedade de um bem imóvel que
ele tenha ao credor fiduciário, que é quem
está emprestando aquele dinheiro.
Caso o devedor pague a totalidade da dívida,
a propriedade volta a ser dele.
Caso o devedor atrase alguma das parcelas dessa
dívida e aí não há um número fixo
de parcelas estipulado em lei, o credor vai
estipular em cada contrato que ele fizer, pode
ser uma, duas, cinco parcelas.
O mais usual é que a partir de
três parcelas o credor possa consolidar a propriedade
em seu nome.
Então, o devedor atrasa o número de parcelas
especificadas em um contrato, o credor notifica o
devedor para que ele pague aquela dívida, caso
ele não pague aquela dívida, o credor pode
consolidar a propriedade em seu nome.
Uma vez consolidada a propriedade em seu nome,
o credor vai ter que realizar um leilão
e esse é o maior número de casos
de leilão exclusivo que ocorre, os chamados leilões
dos bancos, mas não esqueça que não necessariamente
tem que ser um banco, pode ser uma
grande construtora, pode ser qualquer tipo de outra
instituição que realize esse tipo de empréstimo recebendo
em garantia um bem imóvel.
Aqui um pequeno adendo, eu falei no começo
da aula que pode ser um bem imóvel
ou um bem imóvel, isso realmente existe com
os bens imóveis e o exemplo muito claro
é no financiamento de um carro, a pessoa
vai lá e faz a mesma modalidade, só
que com bem imóvel, ela vai transferir a
propriedade daquele veículo para um credor que é
quem está emprestando o dinheiro, mas aqui a
gente vai estudar especificamente os bens imóveis, que
é o que interessa para a gente, já
que esse tipo de contrato de realização fiduciária
de um bem imóvel é o que é
capaz de levar um bem imóvel a um
leilão extrajudicial.
Então vamos a um exemplo prático de uma
forma de contrato de realização fiduciária muito comum,
Maria queria realizar o sonho de comprar sua
casa própria, mas não tinha o valor completo
para comprar um imóvel, vamos supor que esse
imóvel é um apartamento, Maria queria comprar um
apartamento de 500 mil, mas só tinha 100
mil, então a Maria ela compra esse imóvel
e faz um contrato de realização fiduciária com
um banco, aqui vou chamar de Itaú, só
para ficar mais didático, Maria vai ao Itaú
e usa o crédito que ela possui, porque
ela tem um bom salário, porque ela tem
um nome limpo, porque ela é uma boa
opção para que o Itaú ofereça esse dinheiro
em troca de juros, então o Itaú vai
fazer um contrato de realização fiduciária com Maria,
onde o Itaú vai emprestar o dinheiro que
Maria não tem para comprar aquele imóvel e
Maria, que inicialmente seria a proprietária daquele bem,
vai transferir essa propriedade para o Itaú, então
o Itaú vai ficar com a propriedade do
imóvel e Maria vai ficar com a poça
daquele imóvel, Maria pode fazer o que ela
bem desejar com aquele imóvel enquanto ela estiver
na posse, ela pode reformar aquele apartamento, ela
pode alugar aquele apartamento e para nada disso
ela precisa da concordância do Itaú, o Itaú
nem vai saber muitas vezes que ela vai
reformar ou que ela vai alugar aquele apartamento,
porque a Maria ela pode fazer o que
ela quiser enquanto ela estiver com a posse
daquele imóvel, Maria começa pagando aquele financiamento de
forma certinha, vamos supor que é um financiamento
de 420 meses, então Maria paga ali até
100 meses de forma correta, quando chega em
determinado momento, Maria passa por uma dificuldade financeira
e não tem como pagar aquele contrato pontualmente,
as parcelas mensais daquele contrato, então a Maria
atrasa 3 e vamos supor que nesse caso
o contrato de geração financeira que o Itaú
fez com a Maria estipulasse que seriam três
parcelas em atraso para que o banco começasse
a fazer o procedimento de consolidação da propriedade,
então Maria atrasa três parcelas, o Itaú vai
até o cartório de imóveis onde aquele apartamento
está inscrito e vai pedir para que o
cartório de imóveis notifique Maria em mora, ou
seja, para que notifique que Maria oficialmente está
devendo aquele banco, o banco vai mandar uma
notificação para Maria e a partir do recebimento
dessa notificação vai começar um prazo de 15
dias para que Maria possa pagar o que
ela está devendo, logicamente vai pegar aquelas parcelas
que ela está devendo, vai botar a incidência
de juros que ficou estipulado em Se Maria
pagar o que ela está devendo naqueles 15
dias, tudo bem, o contrato de alienação fiduciária
segue como foi pactuado, então ele vai seguir
normalmente até o final.
Se Maria não pagar o que ela deve
em 15 dias, o credor, que é o
Itaú, poderá consolidar a propriedade em seu nome,
para isso o Itaú vai ter que pagar
a guia de TBI daquele imóvel, consolidar a
propriedade em seu nome, que é definitivamente transferir
aquela propriedade e aquela propriedade passa a ser
plena do Itaú e o Itaú necessariamente vai
ter que realizar leilão para tentar vender aquele
imóvel e assim quitar a dívida de Maria.
Então se Maria não pagasse o que ela
devia em 15 dias, o Itaú consolidaria a
propriedade em seu nome, a propriedade seria definitivamente
do Itaú, o Itaú realizaria primeiramente o primeiro
leilão e depois o segundo leilão, caso o
imóvel não seja vendido em primeiro leilão.
Na próxima aula nós vamos estudar como ocorre
o primeiro leilão, qual é o prazo do
primeiro leilão, qual é o prazo do segundo
leilão, qual é o valor que o imóvel
vai em primeiro leilão e qual é o
valor que o imóvel vai em segundo leilão.